the designation healer
refers to the name of a patient
who is operated for the treatment
of a cervical carcinoma
dr and mrs george guy
of the johns hopkins hospital in
baltimore
established this cell strain
which has been in continuous culture
since 1951
hela cells are grown in test tubes where
they may be harvested from the walls by
means of a rubber policeman
the colonies are collected
in petri dishes
containing nutrient fluid
they are transferred later
to the surface of a large sterile glass
slide
and cut into fragments
suitable
for subculture in bottles test tubes
or on cover slips
cells are stimulated by cutting
but this must be done
with sharp knives to avoid excess
trauma
the cut fragments are collected
in a petri dish containing
a nutrient solution
the essential steps in preparing a
culture are now shown
cover glasses are placed on a slide and
plasma is dropped on their surface
the tissues
are now picked up
on the tip of a knife
blade and are transferred to the plasma
they are placed at equidistant points
on the cover glass
an equal amount of embryonic extract is
added and the mixture is stirred
when the clot is set
each slide is placed in a test tube
fluid nutrient is added
and the culture is incubated at body
temperature
here we see the development of a freshly
transferred culture photographed at one
frame per minute
notice the frame counter
in the right hand portion of the field
the middle number
represents the flight of time in minutes
since this portion of the film was
photographed at one frame per minute
and is being projected at 24 frames per
second
what we see on the screen
is accelerated
by a factor of more than one thousand
times the colony spreads
with characteristic shifting motions
of the cells
at higher magnification
we see the advance
of the margin of the outgrowing cells
three arrows point to rotating nuclei
a curious phenomenon encountered in
tissue cultures studied with time-lapse
photography
at higher magnification
we see a nuclear rotation
in an individual cell
this portion of the record is
accelerated
160 times
then the speed
is increased to more than one thousand
times
in order to dramatize the effect
mitosis of normal and abnormal types are
common
three arrows locate elements which will
show normal bipolar divisions
and a single arrow points to a cell
which will produce
a tripolar
mitosis
here is a quadripolar mitosis
frequently
abnormalities of the spindle can be seen
chromosomal movements show a wide
variety
of derangements
the number of chromosomes
is generally between 80 and 90
but sometimes more than 200 chromosomes
can be demonstrated
in dividing cells
of the hela strain
two nuclei
are seen in this giant cell
and here is a giant cell with multiple
nuclei which appears to be in the
process
of degeneration
this portion of the film shows numerous
thread-like cytoplasmic processes
such fillopodia
are typical of the hela cell
we see them in a sequence
where the level of focus
was changed
to show their arrangement in patches
in the right hand portion of this field
the pattern is found even over the area
of the nucleus
in situ
filopodia probably are associated in an
interplay between neighboring cells
here we can see the movements of
intercellular strands
between two cells in vitro
in addition to the surface activity of
the thread-like processes
the cytoplasm often shows characteristic
ruffles
which lead to the engulfment of
nutrient fluid in vacuoles
this process is very commonly found
in gila cultures
we see it taking place in the left-hand
portion of the field
we can also observe twitching movements
of the cytoplasm
which remain unexplained
this sequence and many others
were collected in the course of
investigations
on the behavior of the hela cell
as a part of a cancer research program
cell drinking or pinocytosis
as described by dr warren lewis many
years ago
accounts for the intake of large
quantities of nutrients
cells of this type may ingest
more than one third of their volume in
one hour
the mechanism of pinocytosis
and its consequences
remains one of the most challenging
problems of cell physiology
these records show nutrient intake at
the margin
and the migration of fluid vacuoles
toward the nucleus
these fields were photographed with an
oil immersion objective
active foals on the surface of cells
lead some observers to believe
that this may result
in the formation of mitochondria
however
at a slightly deeper level of focus we
see that filamentous mitochondria are
quite different from the folds of the
surface a view of an entire cell
photographed with phase contrast optics
shows cell organs
such as mitochondria
vacuoles and lipoprotein granules
grouped in characteristic patterns
the juxta nuclear zone or golgi
apparatus
as it is described from fixed
preparations
is probably represented here
in the aggregation
of various
cell organoids
the hela cell
has become a very useful material for
experimental work not only in the study
of cancer
but in the field of general cytology
it is easily cultivated
it exhibits many abnormalities
and is valuable for the cultivation
of a wide variety of viruses
you